so as we are recording today's show we
have hearings going on right now we are
in the midst of Christine Blasi Ford the
accuser of Brett cab the first accuser
of Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
of sexual assault testifying under oath
before the Senate Judiciary Committee
Democrats have been taking turns asking
her questions making statements
Republicans have all opted to yield
their time to a Republican prosecutor
who is just doing everything she can to
cast doubt upon the claims of Christine
Blasi Ford we heard her opening
statement we've read Brett Kavanaugh his
opening statement although he hasn't yet
testified and you know big picture if
you believe that Christine Blasi Ford is
not credible you have to believe that in
a Palo Alto academic they found an
extraordinarily talented actress who was
talented not only in the sense of she
can show up there and appear to truly be
traumatized by what she experienced
three decades ago but also someone who
is willing to interrupt what is probably
a pretty calm life as an academic when
it comes to your day to day to go and
tell what the right wants to say are
fabrications about Brett Kavanaugh so
think about think about what you have to
believe to believe that this is all made
up when you watch Christine Blasi Ford
they looked at who was actually a
classmate of Brett Cavanaugh's during
high school right because they have to
be a classmate and then they went and
they said who can we find who's willing
to show up and make stuff up and also
who happens to be a really talented
actress despite the fact that she's a
career academic that's what you have to
believe they did if you don't believe
that this is credible and someone who
can find out that she's a talented
actress at the age of 51 how many don't
find that out yeah who can pass a
polygraph test with flying colors well
that's hard time polygraph tests i I
don't put almost any weight in them at
this point knowing how how they can be
gamed but again you also need to I mean
think about it though then you have to
get someone who knows how to pass a
polygraph test
is willing to make stuff up about a
former classmate is an extraordinarily
talented actress is willing to come
forward and and interrupt her life as an
academic with something that is only
going to make her experience negativity
for the next who knows how long from all
the people smearing her and is also
trained in defeating a polygraph test
and you better find this person in one
shot because it's just a few people I'm
sure some of them are gonna come out and
reveal this whole ploy what does she
have to gain what incentive exists
particularly when it doesn't even appear
as though this is going to prevent Brett
Kavanaugh from becoming the next Supreme
Court justice of the United States and
for me the biggest and most telling
piece of information here from outside
her actual claims is that mark judge the
witness who has now been named by
multiple people is having information
about what allegedly took place as being
involved in this type of behavior both
during high school and college so on and
so forth he has not been subpoenaed to
testify if there was a serious desire to
figure out who knows what and when and
put them under oath
there is no situation where Marc judge
is not subpoenaed to testify here
professor Ford says she saw mark judge
after the assault working at potomac
village Safeway in his book judge says
on page 93 that he did work as a bag boy
in a local supermarket we got to hear
from this guy it is an injustice that
mark judge has not been subpoenaed here
and then ultimately the question is
going to be could senators turn could
senators turn and say I'm not going to
vote for Brett Kavanaugh as a result of
this I don't know the answer later on in
the show I will have poll results for
you from our audience about what our
audience thinks is going to happen
today's program was made possible in
part by Blink asam / pakman I love bling
cast it's the really perfect app for
anybody who likes politics and learning
and if you're watching or listening to
the David Pakman show I'm sure you'll
love politics and learning and what
blinka studs is take the best and most
popular non-fiction books they condense
them into 15-minute audiobooks that you
can listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy
psychology
economics often we don't have the time
to actually read as many books as we
would like I know that I'm at my limit
for how much I can read and this way you
can absorb the most important valuable
information from books in just 15
minutes maybe on your way to work maybe
on your way to the gym maybe cooking
vegan recipes at home whatever is your
thing and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it and I think you will you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for just about five bucks a
month you can go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n to sign up